we would now like to explore a property
of work done by forces called path
independence so we call that our work is
defined to be an integral of F dot d s
from some initial to some final point
let's look at an example the force that
we're going to look at is the
gravitational force and let's draw a
coordinate system let's take an initial
point and a final point and let's choose
plus X and plus y and our Union factors
I hat NJ had and in this example we're
going to consider the gravitational
force near the surface of the earth
which is constant pointing downwards and
what I'd like to do is consider two
paths I'd like to consider a path that
first path goes straight up and over so
this will be path one it has two legs
and the second path have two will go
horizontal and vertical so that's going
to be path 2 and it has two different
legs and we'd like to evaluate this
integral on both paths now the way we do
that is first off let's start with path
1 we'll call this Y initial and we'll
call that Y final and we'll draw the
gravitational force mg mg on both legs
and now we see that when we do the
integral along this first leg of path 1
the gravitational force is opposite the
direction we're moving the displacement
so the interval will be negative the
force is constant and so the work done
is simply minus mg times Delta Y which
is y final minus y initial on that first
part now on the second part this is a
right angle and because it's a right
angle the dot product is 0 so that's the
total work done on path 1 now on path 2
well again let's just draw our forces we
have gravity down and we have gravity
down and we can see that once again on
the
first horizontal leg of path to this
integral is zero because it's moving
perpendicular to the force the direction
of just along the path and on this leg
just as on that leg there the
gravitational force is down the integral
is negative we get exactly the same
result now what we like to do is
consider a more general path rather than
these two horizontal and vertical legs
so let's draw a coordinate system again
let's introduce I and let's introduce F
plus y and plus X and now let's consider
a path which is moving like that now on
this path what we want to do is break it
down into horizontal and vertical pieces
horizontal vertical horizontal vertical
horizontal vertical horizontal vertical
horizontal vertical and let's focus on
one of these pieces which has a
displacement D s going from one point to
another now if we blow that up so we
have our displacement D s then what we
have here is a displacement DX in the
horizontal direction and dy in the
vertical direction and so we see again
that when we compute this work and our
gravitational force is downward then the
horizontal displayed part of this
displacement the dot product in the
horizontal direction 0 only the vertical
part cancels and so when we add up the
work along these horizontal and vertical
pieces only the vertical piece counts
we're just adding up the D Wives until
we get Y final minus y initial now let's
be a little more analytic here and write
out our D s as a vector DX I hat plus dy
J hat and our gravitational force as
minus mg J hat now the work is the
integral from the initial to the final
place
of F G dot d s and so when we do that we
have minus mg J hat dot DX I hat plus dy
J hat and from our initial to the final
place and notice that we have J hat dot
I hat they are perpendicular so that dot
product is zero and J hat J hat is one
and so what we're left with here in the
integral is simply now we're integrating
from Y initial to Y final because we
only have minus mg dy and that's what we
said before only the vertical parts are
adding up and so when you do this
integral M G is a constant we get mg
times y final minus y initial and that
agrees with what we had before so this
type of force is an illustration of a
force where the work done is independent
of the path we choose from the initial
to the final place